foreign
what is the best way to educate our
children when that question arises the
discussion eventually turns to the issue
of school choice you know support for
national school choice week advocating
for alternative options to Public
Schools such as Charter and magnitude
the use of public money to fund private
schools has had its fair share of
controversy supporters say vouchers help
students succeed but opponents say they
siphon away crucial Public School
resources
my name's Neil McCluskey I am the
director of the center for educational
Freedom at the Cato Institute I've been
studying education policy for 20 years
or so you know at Cato we do work in all
sorts of aspects of school choice you
know the fiscal aspect the academic
outcomes but I think in we've sort of in
particular uh created a an emphasis on
how does it affect society does it bring
Society together
it's actually not surprising that a lot
of people aren't sure what school choice
is because we use that term and it can
mean a lot of things
most basically school choice means
instead of government funding schools
that it establishes and runs so we call
those typically Public Schools Money
Follows kids to schools that their
families choose I think what people
would most readily associate that with
are School vouchers where basically it's
usually the state money that would be
spent on a child of public school
instead follows that child to a private
school or could fall to a public school
lots of different options but what's new
about it is the ability to take that to
a private school but many people may be
familiar with Charter Schools which are
kind of a hybrid of this where
uh some private group says hey we want
to start a school we'd like it so that
people's money can or the tax Money
Follows kids to that school if their
families choose it and so it's not as
simple as money just following the kids
it is
basically a private group asking a
school board often or a state entity hey
can we start this school money will
follow kids to it and they have to do a
lot of things like public schools do so
it's not quite full school choice
um but maybe people are probably
familiar with that but then we have lots
of other school choice many people may
know magnet schools those are public
schools usually established by a school
district that has something special
about it the original idea behind those
was to have people able to choose a
school that's a little different in
order to more voluntarily bring together
people of different races it could also
be different economic backgrounds and
things like that
the general idea is that
parents families can choose a school
rather than just being assigned to one
so to know the history school choice you
got to know something about the history
of public schools there was concern that
families that kids would not get
educated and would not be molded into
good citizens in a democracy unless
government took charge of education and
it has a lot of intuitive appeal the
idea that okay this is how we ensure we
get the people we need
and you start this movement to say okay
we're only going to have public schools
government-run schools
but school choice you know it starts to
develop as a distinct idea at the same
time first you need hey we only go to
government schools to then have the idea
that wait there should be an alternative
where Money Follows students we saw lots
of discussion about this first and
foremost of Roman Catholics and so they
start to say as Catholic communities get
bigger we need to have money go to our
schools because these schools stand
against what we believe they're imposing
ideas that we don't want and then in the
19 actually 1990 the first Voucher
Program modern voucher program in
Milwaukee there was actually something
called town tuitioning in Maine and
Vermont long before that before the turn
of the 20th century
but they put into practice then this
idea of money should follow kids to
schools they think are best a lot of
that was about test scores and academic
achievement but more and more the move
has been as we get into the
today
about how do we have an education system
that is best for diverse free societies
and we see the need for it in these
battles like they're going on right now
do you allow kids to access AP
African-American studies what books can
be in the library how do you teach about
our history
now how do you deal with gender identity
issues and so this is I think becoming
the major driver of school choice now is
a recognition that the free Society
an education system consistent with the
free Society has to be based
in individual family choices of what
they think is right in education and the
freedom for educators to educate as they
think is right and then people freely
come together on education that they
agree on
we've seen huge increases in these
school choice laws and in States passing
bills since really 2021 there had been
study growth before then but covid
really drove A Renewed powerful interest
in expanding private school choice
because what it revealed to many people
who were you know often very satisfied
with their Public Schools was you know
what
sometimes even a public school I like
cannot satisfy everyone
clearly people have different
philosophies different values about how
to raise their kids you know what is the
right time for kids see what age to
start making decisions for themselves we
don't even agree on that and we don't
have incontrovertible proof that one
approach to child rearing works and one
doesn't in part because we often
disagree on what the ultimate outcome is
that we want for our kids and that's
what we're seeing manifested in these
School battles
I think we're going to see an overall
short-term upward Trend in school choice
I think we're going to see a long term
uh increase in school choice and
acceptance that education should be
fundamentally grounded in the decisions
of free decisions of families and
Educators but in the medium term I think
we are going to see a Slowdown in school
choice prod progress and more debates
about
it's good choice good as a concept is it
bad why we people arguing why we need
public schools and and that's probably
good that we'll have a debate about the
fundamental reasons that we have
education delivered in one way or
another